those were the beginnings of the classic  sitcoms and all the ones that should  they contact showing the mary tyler  moore show and when you think back to  classic sitcoms you think of you think  of that ray romano remembers Mary Tyler  Moore her style was very real ET caught  up with the Everybody Loves Raymond star  who reflected on how Mary changed the  face of TV  is to play a career woman you know that  when there really weren't any on TV and  she was just brilliant with the comedy  there was always some deeper meaning to  whatever chuckles deep I mean it was a  sitcom which can be big and broad but  there was something so real about her  and that's kind of gonna leave that our  show that was one of the shows we tried  to emulate I'm here to talk about Gus  patron  it's sad that she's gone but she didn't  she did a lot for all of us really  [Music]